all right well we have our very own nate
tannenbaum in for sally today what a
treat great to have you oh great to be
here especially when there's so much
going on
so much that heat man it always takes a
couple weeks to really kind of adjust to
it yeah and that's exactly why the
national weather service issues these
excessive heat warnings the first time
that we get into the 105 to 110 range
just to say hey we all need to be extra
careful and watch out for our health
take a look outside you can see the
camera behind us bouncing around a
little bit that was the strat looking up
to the north now we got this camera it
is the moleski family of companies
building which is basically the bank of
america building up there in the near
northwest part of town at rainbow and
u.s 95 you can sort of see the flags
waving out here at the gas stations
officially we're at 108 at reid
international but let's check what's
happening in your neighborhood oh my the
air force base you're at 111 henderson
at 110 and again these numbers are not
the official reading out of read but
obviously things are very toasty out
there green valley 109 even triple
digits in the far northwest centennial
hills sky canyon the lakes are at 104
and you want to talk about hot how about
a buck 22 out of death valley take away
20. baby that is an awfully warm 102 for
you over the hump and prop 105. now
again the excessive heat warning is on
track to expire here in about three
hours but obviously you have felt the
wind picking up so that 109 is a tie for
the record high for the date we did 109
yesterday which set a new record high
for that date a little odd weather
phenomenon the low this morning at 89
may be one of those odd records for the
warmest ever overnight low so two days
in a row at 109 yesterday it set a new
record today it ties the record nowhere
near the record high of 112 tomorrow as
we're forecasting a 105 because of the
wind 30 mile an hour winds go up to 40
miles an hour tomorrow hanging on to 35
miles an hour on monday slacking off a
little bit into the rest of the week
junior weather buddy nerds we're keeping
an eye on some clouds in northwestern
arizona but on the bigger picture it is
just plain hot and for your family and
friends across the nation severe
thunderstorm watches for parts of
montana wyoming south dakota tornado
watches for nebraska iowa and missouri
now your eight day forecast we start
with a low tonight at 83 and winds
gusting to 30. we'll go for 106 tomorrow
98 on monday 96 on tuesday but then the
heat comes back so you still have to be
very safe out there we'll talk more
about the wind advisory and how long
that's going to last when we get back
together on our next newscast sasha